[Music]
hey darling
sir what was your name again
it's Hannah Hannah Alexandra Harris but
I go by Layla Layla have been for about
seven to nine years now as a working
girl
slash escort and tell me about your
childhood you grew up where uh I grew up
in
um
a group a little bit everywhere in
Southern California
um Inland outskirts by the beach
um I was really mostly home alone with
my brother or we were at school and if
we were in school we were home alone my
mom was not around we didn't have Dad he
had a dad but he was you know further
away in the museum so we were mostly
just my brother and I you know just kind
of kicking it and growing up with each
other
um taking care of one another how would
you describe your childhood in general
um it was it was really uh it was really
shitty
um but it was great when him and I were
together you know we're best friends so
we kept each other that float you know I
learned I learned a lot through him by
having to buckle up you know and take
responsibility
any abuse in your childhood
um
a lot of mental abuse emotional abuse
there's been some physical obvious here
and there but um
yes there's a piece of
pieces of my life for sure
um but um I got through it you know so
you graduated high school uh I almost
graduated high school I ended up having
to drop out in 11th grade to take care
of my brothers slash
um children I did go back and go to
Adult School to get my GED and I did
pass I did get my GED at the age of 19.
and dropped out of 11th grade when I was
17 and then I lost 18 when I was 19. so
today you're
you're here on Skid Row you're working
the street the skid row right uh after I
got my GED
um I got my CNA certificate license
whatever I'm gonna say whatever and I
went straight to work
um I went to school and I went straight
to work so I've always been really busy
I've always been a very busy busy busy
busy little B and um
and so uh how old are you
I'm 32 October 15th 1989. that's the
same company
drugs became in the picture somewhere
okay so yeah so my
um
my mother was at home she was a she grew
up she was a um she was an adult you
know
industry so to speak trying to work a
way up in there you know so and I and we
knew it but we didn't you know whatever
but so she would come home and she'd be
able you know all sloth and about that
she was doing much for a living but um
she was just trying to live she was
trying to stay alive you know I look
back on it now she's trying to stay
alive she wasn't all [__] up because
she wanted to be [__] up she was a
piece of [__] she was [__] because
she had to be [__] up because she's
trying to live you know um I see things
and two different ways what was your mom
doing for for work uh she was um she did
she was a stripper and then she had an
escorting business and then she um and
she worked at home I was in an apartment
and we got a home in Mount helix or
something like that and it was really
big beautiful home
um and she got engaged and she had her
own office and then her glass doors and
everything it was really cool I was
bitching and she was calling she was
still stripping too you know she was
doing all of it she was doing the whole
the whole nine it was really cool
um because she'd come home with fast
money you know it was just it was cool
to see her you know rise because we grew
up poor we were really poor
it didn't last long
um uh every summer I go to my
grandmother's my brother's brother's
dad's and she would um be alone you know
and do her own thing and uh and I'll be
in with my grandmother and my brother's
dad and my brother and his dad they put
jumped you know and he was running
alcohol and drugs more than I was at the
time I was around my grandmother was
very reserved proper like you know very
um
just like a queen so to speak like very
clean very
um perfect
and just wanted to see me just be
yeah great and everything I did
um and I wanted to do that for her too
but um
and I was trying I was doing really good
at trying and doing it but she died and
when she died
I took it I took a
I flip a [__] that's so to speak and I
started drinking a lot and doing a lot
of um things I wouldn't usually do
because before I just spoke a little bit
weed maybe and understand how my friends
drink coffee you know everyone did
everything they wanted to do I didn't do
nothing I was I was literally I was a
square but I kicked it with everyone who
did everything you know and um then she
punched me and I started experimenting
with a lot of things I did everything
they deciding except for acid um anyone
to ask because I couldn't control it I
like to control things I'm actually sure
anything I put in my body
um so I got real into alcohol though I
became famous alcoholic because so to
speak I would go to work I'm gonna get
off work drink or drink fall asleep wake
up eat a little bit go to work
this became a repetitive thing so we're
doing becoming a functional alcoholic
actually and I don't do uh some trouble
uh I was blocking out for a minute and I
was driving and one day when I um I uh I
blocked out and I hit something
and I go ahead
because I just remember it was Flash you
know just like you know um
something happened I don't know I felt
like the light switch turned off you
know and then turned it back on and I
remember like seeing a semi and you
bending over like this and like what the
[__] is going on was on the wrong side
of the road and then turned off again
and I was in the car and I was driving I
was young to my house right here I was
paying for a room I never made a list
and I brought two beers I go to my baby
daddies who was my baby daddy at the
time it was just someone on scene and I
knocked that door and he came to the
door it took me forever and my face was
[__] up so I just got into a car
accident I didn't know my face was
trying to feel the burn you know but I
was like let's bounce and beers and [__]
you know I don't know he was answering
and then he finally answered when he
answered he came to the door and he came
to the door and this quote [__] he came
into the door and quilt like this she
was a king or something it was the
weirdest thing ever and he's like what
the [__] is going on
actually alert you know but it's really
incoherencing time and he's like what
the hell happened I was like my car
crashes so he's like what it's like get
inside the inside and I got inside and
when I got inside I
I don't know what I hit I think I hit a
semi or semi hit me or hit I hit
something White
and or something hit me and I'm really
thinking something hit me but you know
but you never found out I never found
out
um you didn't kill anybody
I didn't kill anybody there's some weird
stuff with that without a whole scenario
that whole situation because he ended up
so he ended up hiding the car and they
were gonna go and toss it and strip it
and all kinds of stuff I was like yeah
I'll just I'll just sell it to pick and
pull and get 240 for it [__] it you know
someone won it you know they can pull
the pieces out for it or whatever so
that's what we did instead but um uh so
it really is it was very Honda DX you
know and what was weird about when I got
the car originally I paid for I had an
Audi and my my my uh shifting went out
my end
like uh stick shifts I had a death
switch one night I was talking driving a
lot right I was I was doing bad things
and I stopped myself and I I punched
myself and consequented myself and
everything but anyways um the the clutch
went out and the clutch went out
um
I had to sell it because I was already
putting too much money into I was like
[__] [__] another more money put into
this [__] like [__] this [__] so and you
selling that getting the money for that
and getting this right Honda well as
soon as I started buying cars I noticed
the cars I was buying were always
something wrong with them as soon as I
got them this red Honda the brakes would
slip
so I've got a light and I have my brakes
on it is such a slip like you know but I
just have to pump pump my my braid just
to see still or else I start to go
during a red light you know or um as if
my bracelet should be cut and slipped
and I was gonna die like someone's
trying to kill me is what I was feeling
like and so every car I got something
was going on and it like as if I had
like a little like grilling underneath
my car trying to like it was literally
kill me and um it was it was the
craziest thing so I had to stop driving
for a while because I was drinking
driving and that was happening and and
so on and so forth so um uh
so yeah so
um uh my baby daddy ended up he ended up
being my baby daddy you know we ended up
having kids and
um
I got multiples pierced I got [__] up
black I got multiple stairs and then I
ended up at his house again and then
he's like [__] this [__] put a baby and
exclude piercings out like a month later
because I found I was pregnant and then
we made a family and then that was a
really dark relationship too
uh went through a lot of stuff and
that's when the drugs came into play
mostly was uh so you went you you
eventually went to harder drugs yeah
yeah
so yeah what are your drugs today uh I
don't I don't do drugs I'm kidding I do
Fentanyl and I do cavities those are
drugs um those are drugs today to
everyone's knowledge yes they are
um but if I were to say it anyway
if I can say anyway
I feel like the only kind of dragon
really is in this world is best if I
mean you know I've learned that
methamphetamine is a man-made drug you
know and it's probably one of the most
dangerous drugs I put across because
I've done it one time and it was Puda
you know it was a real stuff and it made
me feel like super mad I felt like I
could lose a car and I didn't want to do
nothing else but smoke that and [__] and
lift cars and still I want to do all of
that because I wanted I wanted to get
away with it I wanted it felt like no
one could catch me
you know and I did it for three days and
uh two or three days in those two or
three days I was like really it's more
and then my baby daddy is like uh
chicken pipe wrapped it up pressure is
like what I'll do this again
we never did it again but I know he did
I know he did I was doing other things
but um you have kids
be we had a beautiful beautiful two
beautiful baby boys
so I'm sorry how many children do you
have
I don't know
I was also a certain mother I got some
discharge paper from the hospital and to
learn how to serve other and I've been
making money this whole time with some
other stuff and I haven't learned I was
terminally ill cancer patient and I was
also helping in Cancer Society but I'm
also dying really badly and there's
nothing that could help me and basically
everyone was up to my life because I
ended up being a lot of money I have a
lot of money I have a lot of money and I
don't have anybody that can help me with
it
so you you owe a lot of money no I have
a lot you have a lot of money I have a
lot of money the state keeps on sending
the same check over and over so you have
a lot of money but you're here on Skid
Row working the streets
I'm trying to find somebody
in trust because I haven't found anybody
I can trust you in any other way no no
Suburban where I know regular way no no
community no or else I'm just trying
different ways and also going through it
I'm going through a lot of things I went
through
um
I'm in a relationship with a
relationship and some stuff went down
with us and
where are you staying now
I know I can be saying anywhere I can
stay in Hollywood in my apartment I have
an apartment in Hollywood
my apartment but a lot of stuff from
down there uh someone's trying to kill
me seriously I'm not joking
um I wish it was a joke I wish at the
end of all this we were like ah we got
you but
um there's some serious stuff going on
in my life that I don't know what to do
about it why do you think someone's
trying to kill you
see it I'm starting to see it I'm
starting to see
I'm starting to see what's what's
killing me
and I can see them in the people
they don't have a clue of what they're
doing is they're just doing things by
what someone else says you know since
they're doing things before they can't
see
so it has to be some kind of blind
Community or deaf Community or something
weird I don't know
but um I'm also an arbitrary instructor
and by the way
I did that when I I've been doing that
for what arbitrary instructor what is an
arbitrary instruction it says a lot of
decoding and and learning what was
really read in between the lines of of
all paperwork and and we all are
we're all given you know our birth
certificates and our social securities
and our names and everything and um
um
and we just go oh this is our stuff yeah
we don't we don't research it or
anything I mean like we don't get to
know who we are but we are we're so much
more all of us are all important and we
have many other other things that we do
in our lives that we don't have to be
all in Skid Row The Skittle doesn't have
to be scared like this it really doesn't
you know that's what I'm saying there's
three things to do anything that that
resolves everything in anyone's life
seriously
what's your biggest regret in your life
um
always leaving
your children
never left my children
I've never left my children
uh my children and I were ripped apart
by Society
in a broadcast it is really [__] up
um I had a lot of dark in my life I'm
trying to give you the dark happy
version
I'm trying to
what's the hardest thing for you to
deal with or look at
pictures
the pictures
I'm afraid of looking at pictures on on
someone I haven't seen my kids in nine
years not because I'm a bad mom
but because
you're more endangering together as a
family
to the community but the community was
more endangering to us
as a family and individually
so we had they have the upper hand on us
but we try to save them first before us
and we were still separated
and it's only signature
it's your biggest fear now people
people
said not every stranger is danger
so I had optimistic view of people
around me
but you're working the street you're
you're meeting some of the oh realist
yes for the most dangerous people out
there probably I'm a realist I'm with it
I'm with the [__] the Poo the do all of
it I got it on I know it to the top to
the middle to the bottom
I know all of what people are
and no one can look me in the eye and
tell me something that I don't that I
don't know
and uh I guess I I earned that and I
didn't know somebody can earn something
like that and it's not something that
anybody can really be earned unless you
are
trying to be removed your whole life and
someone recognizes that I guess
um
but I get people's benefit out still
until this day um I can know anything
online about them but instead I just uh
I give them benefit out I get to know
them before before I want to dig up
anything if I want to dig up anything
and I don't I'll ever dig for anything I
don't think for nothing ever
and
then it will
not liberal Layla what would you say is
the most important lesson you've learned
in your life
having children
um
and not the answer to everything
it's not um
cherry on top of everything
it's um
it's encouragement
it's crazy did you raise your kids
in five years I did and then we were
mirrored apart
illegally legally with a lot of love
from the authority
and uh
and they're my most raised eyebrow now
as Authority you know
I have a really crazy life that's
nothing you know so much it's nothing
but it's you know something you know but
there's so much more
so much more what are you not telling me
because it's gonna go on for them
forever there's so many things that so
many like
and I told you I mean if I told you
nothing happens like a sliver you know
I came from Vegas and so much happened
in Vegas and I was alone in Vegas you
know
important not just me there's no one no
one Just Me Myself and I no kids no no
boyfriend no baby daddy you know nothing
just me working the streets in the snow
the rain the coldest the everything by
myself in a trenches I mean like doing
the damn thing and you know working I
mean I worked through Oakland even I
mean I was just doing it and I was crazy
about to put myself in really dangerous
situations
but I was I was being taken care of also
by an Angel or something because
I should have died so many times what
was what's been your darkest point of
your life
love at first sight
darkest
your situation now seems pretty
pretty bleak
sorry
Mila thank you very much for sharing
some of your story
be careful out there